hey y'all I am so excited to be joining
you from the US and to be helping close
out this amazing NDC Porto conference
and thank you for joining my session I
hope you're doing well and staying safe
hello I'm in recovery for type coercion
an automatic semicolon insertion and my
name is David maybe you're like me and
you've been too burned a time or two by
JavaScript burned in development and in
production
well JavaScript has caused many a
developer more than a fair share of
indigestion over the years my first
introduction to JavaScript was around
1997 at that time I was a visual basic
developer and I started building web
apps with ASP active server pages
what would we what we would now refer to
as classic ASP and I kept reading about
people doing this thing called dynamic
HTML and I wanted to learn how to make
my websites more dynamic dynamic cursors
alert boxes rollover buttons objects
that bounced around on the screen the
more obnoxious the better am i right
well my career really started to take
off and get serious as a web developer
around the dot-com in the early 2000s I
joined a hot start up to build an
interactive commercial web app and I
needed to support both Internet Explorer
and Netscape it seemed like so many cool
companies were having great success with
javascript I wanted to be a cool
development but it was a it sure was a
struggle to learn
and there was a lot of trial and error
with JavaScript anything goes and it
often does if you are a web developer
around this time you probably remember
sites like dynamic drive I spent
countless hours trying to understand the
JavaScript code I lifted from sites like
dynamic drive and they worked on their
websites
examples and everything but when I
tasted the exact same code into my app
it didn't work and I couldn't figure out
why JavaScript is amazing except when it
isn't
there's quirks and weirdness in the
JavaScript language that continue to
exist even to this day unexpected
behavior and baffle even the most
seasoned JavaScript development let's
take a look at a few of those examples
of that were key behavior javascript has
a special value named man in a n which
stands for not a number which is not to
be confused with null or undefined
so given this statement if the variable
F is not a number is NaN then the entire
operation of the result will be man
which can lead to lots of fun time
sometimes it's very difficult to find
where the man is occurring in your code
and it's you know maybe you're looking
for some clues so how can we test in our
code for man it's it's not a number but
what what's the underlying value of man
what can we test for is man greater than
or equal to zero
no is it less than or equal to zero no
is what's the type of the man object
it's a number
gee thanks a lot JavaScript for making
our lives
soon easy to use this this tools in math
we have something we call commutative
properties so mathematically true if we
take a plus B and you know these these
are equal statements right order of
operations and everything in JavaScript
when we evaluate this type of statement
it's not always predictable there's
cases where it's true and there's cases
where it can be false so if we were to
say you know in is this code true or
false
no it doesn't always equal true if we
try to look at is point 1 plus point 2
equal to 0.3 no it's not what what is
0.1 plus point 2 and in JavaScript it's
point 3 something it's not this is not
just a JavaScript problem this is
floating math floating point math and
for computers as hard apparently seems
like we were smart people we should be
able to figure these things out this is
the kind of stuff that we still have to
deal with here's an example if we round
this gigantic number we get 0 as we
would expect you know it's it's less
than 0.5 so you know it's going to round
down to 0 however if we around this very
long number and if you notice the only
thing that changes between the two
numbers is the very last place from 2 to
3 if we round this number in JavaScript
we get 1 and tested I've got 99 problems
but JavaScript ain't one point zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero
let's let's talk about sorting and
JavaScript if we were to sort this array
of two and ten we would get ten and two
as we would expect because javascript is
being really helpful in ignoring the
fact that these are numbers not instead
of strings um if we map things like an
array of strings and we we want to parse
these numbers we would expect an array
of of tens right you know we get
something silly like like this Thanks
JavaScript and then the you know there
there are types inside JavaScript and
there's this type of operator that helps
us to determine what these types are so
if we say what's the type of undefined
it's it's undefined type of true that's
a boolean type of string it's a it's a
string so far so good
a type of one is a number but if we say
type of an object well it's an object
and that's that's great if we say type
of would array it's an object type of
null
it's an object the black art of figuring
out the type of variables I don't know
good luck and then we've got things like
you know we've got this helpful operator
called number number is supposed to
convert things over to the numeric
values of these things so if we take
null and pass it to number on the other
end we get zero so Nowell must be zero
right it must be equal to zero
no no is null greater than zero
no is no less than zero no there's no
greater than or equal to zero this one
is true I have no idea
less than or equal to zero
it's not zero but it's somewhere I don't
know and then we've got these weird
concepts in in the JavaScript language
like false e truthy and falsy values
false no is considered to be a false e
value undefined is false e empty string
and B equal to false zero is false
Nandy false yeah good luck and then
there's things like you know powerful
features in the JavaScript language like
regular expressions you know I have a
problem I'll solve it with a regular
expression now I've got nan problems so
we take something like this
we have whack equal to this regular
expression of a we want to test the
string JavaScript and yes there is an a
in JavaScript and then we test we turn
around we test another string and that's
false
what well it turns out that the regular
expression object itself maintains state
and so the index changed from underneath
this that's can be really helpful and
hard to easy to to figure out and then
we got some syntax quirks like you know
we've got this function we want to
return an object and what should this
troll return when we call this function
it returns undefined what I thought we
were returning an object well JavaScript
tries to be really helpful and there's
no you know syntax matters and so it
sees this return statement with nothing
else after it and thinks oh well I need
to insert a semicolon here thanks
JavaScript let's talk about arrays
arrays are dynamic in JavaScript that's
pretty cool
you can just start stuffing things into
arrays like if we want to index one and
change that value to one our index 3 and
get that a value of 2 we can do all we
can willy-nilly add things to an array
and when we're done we can take array
dot length to figure out how many items
are in our array and we get 11 11 items
in our array um this almost makes sense
right
maybe well we can do some weird things
with arrays - we can index negative 1 we
can say array dot s we can start just
really nearly adding properties to our
array and when we take a read out length
now what's what's our length now it's
still 11 why javascript has been around
for years and we're smart people right
why haven't we fixed these things how
did this happen javascript arguably the
most important most universal most
pervasive language in computer science
history so far if it's so important why
is it so terrible at times well let's
look back at the birth of JavaScript
it's a classic example of how so many
things get created in software and it's
funny but it's the kind of funny that
makes you want to cry this is Marc
Andreessen he was at the University of
Illinois and was one of the people who
created the very first internet browser
the NCSA mosaic Marc later moved to
Silicon Valley and he helped start a
little company named next
in February of 1995 mark hires a man
named Brandon Ike Brandon was hired to
create a scripting language for Netscape
the original plan was to implement
scheme a dialect of lisp in May of 1995
and recent calls in Brendan and says
Randall pants
we need a demo of that new scripting
language like yesterday it's Brendan sir
sure thing scheme and Netscape is going
to be awesome
Brande forum your hilarious scheme in
the browser oh man you've got me going
there seriously though it's got to look
like Java let's call it mocha mocha Java
get it
we need a demo by the end of next week
people aren't convinced that this thing
is going to fly I'm gonna need you to
come in on Saturday ok and Sunday dude
so what does Brendan did he does what
any of us would do in this situation he
works like a heroic machine through the
nights and ten days ten whole days later
he delivers mocha the first version of
JavaScript was created in ten days
that's both incredibly amazing and
absolutely horrified good work boogaloo
ship it but SERDES only do I still need
to ship it it's the most classic move in
all program ship it Moka was supposed to
be for amateurs and designers anyway who
cares if it's but
the real professionals are going to use
Java Java is the future twist Java it
was supposed to be language for the web
for the browser and we know how that
played out Java the applets rimmer you
know right once they'll everywhere well
I think it's interesting to look at some
of the other things on the timeline
during the early days of JavaScript
after mocha is is created in ten days it
goes through a couple of iterations I
mean the code itself doesn't really
change but it goes through a couple of
names they got renamed to live script
for a little while and then JavaScript
in December of 95
Netscape releases I think it was version
2 beta 1 or something like that that
includes JavaScript
well Microsoft takes notice and they see
this cool new scripting language that's
in Netscape and they decide to reverse
engineer what Netscape has has done and
but if you remember this if you were
around this time they didn't call it
javascript javascript is trademarked by
sun so they called theirs jscript well
Microsoft did such a good job of reverse
engineering that they reversed
engineered everything down to the
littlest detail including all the quirks
and and things that JavaScript did weird
now this prompted Netscape to go on the
defense
so Netscape is seeing how a Microsoft
work at least around this this time in
history Microsoft's classic example of
strategy of embracing spending and
extinguishing technology right
Netscape knows if Microsoft has their
they'll run away with the language and
you know ultimately destroy it or or
certainly you know replace it with
something else
or you know who knows how that may have
turned out so in an offensive move
against Microsoft Netscape decides to
standardize the JavaScript language so
they went and talked to the obvious
candidate for the standardization the
w3c and the w3c he responds with well
know things we have more important
things to focus on like marquee and the
blink tag
well thanks w3c keep keep up the good
work we'll move on so Netscape this
approaches ACMA International which is a
standards based organization in sweet
and Eknath takes on the project and they
form what's called the tc39 this is the
technical steering committee for the
JavaScript language and eventually after
a little while of work the tc39 creates
a document called Eknath 260 equi 262 is
is what we have is it's what continues
to evolve to this day it is the formal
language spec for the JavaScript
language now the reason is called Eknath
and we hear this strange word used a lot
JavaScript you know again at this time
and still is to this day although it's
you know it's arguably unenforceable
javascript is a trademark of sun and
they couldn't use JavaScript as the name
of the language in the spec so they
named it Etna script this is where
Eklund script comes from ACMA script is
the language specification JavaScript as
we find in browsers is just one of
several implementations of that standard
so oh you know fast forward a little bit
Eckman
releases es2 and 1998 it's basically
just some updates for ISO certification
and then we get ps3 in 99 which includes
some things like regex try/catch and
some better string handling now moving
forward in time we we look at es5 was
adds strict mode and reduces some of the
quirkiness of the language there's JSON
library support added and es6 is a major
update adding classes and generators and
arrow functions promises and many more
features wait hang on a second
what the crap 10 years between es3 and
es5 man if you were a web developer
doing during these years that's a long
time and it was a real struggle right to
build web applications using ES 3 until
es 5 came along so what happened here
well Microsoft won the first browser
wars with ie6 around 2001 and basically
they sat back to watch the world burn
Microsoft won but we as web developers
lost by 2008 now you know es 4 was being
worked on and by 2008 es 4 was was so
big and so complex and there was no
consensus among the members of the
standards committee and for technical
and political reasons you know there was
we there was representatives from
Microsoft and Yahoo and Adobe that were
all part of the committee so an
important decision was made to abandon
es 4 and they took some incremental
changes that was slated for ESA
and renamed it es5 and set the path
forward well there's an interesting side
note here if you remember during those
days
Macromedia flash was a plugin that once
dominated the web people created amazing
interactive interfaces and games with
this animation plug-in what you couldn't
do with JavaScript you know you you
solved with with flash in flash if you
were building anything more than maybe a
cartoon you needed to use its
programming language called ActionScript
which looked a lot like JavaScript
that's because ActionScript was another
implementation of the Ekman script
standard so between 1999 and 2009 the
developers at flash were early
implementers adopters of the proposed es
for spec and they were helping to push
the language forward by 2006
ActionScript 3 had classes and
interfaces it had a type system there
were news default function parameters
modules packages it had a lot of great
language feature flash developers could
argue that what they had in 2006 is
still better than what we have in
JavaScript today les takes a quick look
at a few other major milestones of the
web that helped to influence JavaScript
over the years
in 2001 we talked about Internet
Explorer 6 coming out and you know that
helped or hurt in some cases you know
set Java the JavaScript language for a
long time but around 2004 we see some
tools like Firefox comes out and there's
a web developer tools it gets created
the Firefox browser
and Gmail comes out on Gmail along with
Google Maps and you know took the
browser apps to a whole new level never
thought possible and they demonstrated
to the world what the browser was
capable jQuery made a huge impact on web
developers because it was for the you
know it wasn't the only library that did
this but this is you know it jQuery
really took off in popularity but it was
sort of we know jQuery gave us a single
API that normalized the differences
between the browser's jQuery and its
popular plug-in community made web
application development accessible
taking away a lot of pain not all of the
pain but a lot of it but web apps could
be built by mere mortals like like you
and me with the help of jQuery and then
around 2008 Google Chrome Kames comes
along and it takes the web by storm
Microsoft has been coasting on ie6 for
years and people are desperate for a
better browser the chrome adoption grows
so quickly that it stirs Microsoft to
start releasing new versions of ie and
in 2009 we get the es 5 harmony and
around this time the Internet Explorer 8
comes out and then you know there's a
just for a reference there is a 15 year
gap between HTML 4.1 CSS 2 and then the
release of HTML 5 but that's that's a
whole nother story let's let's go back
to the tc39 there's 10 years between es
3 es 5 and then there's another 6 years
from es 5 the es 6 the tc39 knew that
they needed to fix their process
and but adding new features of the
JavaScript language is not a trivial
task the first rule of the tc39 Fight
Club is don't break the internet
backwards compatibility has always been
one of the highest priorities when
making changes to the language which is
why some of the work e behavior still
exists it can't it continues to exist on
purpose it's codified in the spec
because if they fixed it
it would break code all over the world
that expects that weird quirky behavior
the internet would collapse and the
world would explode I submit my
hypothesis that the Deathstar
super weapon is actually a very powerful
JavaScript emitter that's right the tc39
committee is made up of developers
implementers framework authors and
academics the Eknath 262 document is
currently more than 1,200 pages since
2015 the tc39 has been on a better
process that has had a better process in
place and they do things like they meet
every two months they meet for three
days at a time the discussions are time
boxed the entire process is open and you
can follow their progress through their
repos and meeting notes so everything's
done out in the open in order for a new
idea for the JavaScript language to make
it into the Ekman script standard that
idea has to be moved through a series of
stages stage 0 is the first stage and of
course the tc39 process is a zero-based
index
a bunch of nerds state zero is the idea
stage also known as the strawman state
lots of new ideas get submitted at stage
zero and in stage one is the proposal
state there's an agreed-upon version
draft of this idea a proposal
essentially states what the problem is
how it might be solved and some of the
known technical challenges a polyfill
might be created as a proof of concept
and a polyfill is like a JavaScript
library that demonstrates how this new
idea might behave or look at this time a
champion of it on the tc39
is selected to take ownership and to see
this proposal through the rest of the
state in stage 2 this is the the formal
spec stage a specification draft has
created the syntax and semantics and
backwards compatibility all that those
kinds of details are are stressed out as
part of the idea and then stage 3 is
called the candidate stage the
specification has been finished and this
this is a signal to the rest of the
world that they can start you know
trying to implement this new change in
the specification and get real-world
usage and feedback so at this time
browsers and other implementations of
Java Script or Eggman script and choose
to add these new this new feature
usually it's behind a feature flag or a
plug-in here and or something like that
so that people can test it and this is
where we see chrome add new features to
do v8 which is the chrome JavaScript
engine behind feature flags you can turn
those on or off and in node.js which
also uses chrome v8 as its engine though
feature flags can be used like command
line switches now when something reaches
stage 3 it's very close to being in the
spec but it it's it's still no guarantee
that this is going to make it into the
final standard no there's enough
feedback if there's enough feedback that
that comes back to say this you know
this is not ready for production this is
not ready for the real world
then then some proposals may never reach
the next stage or they may stay in that
stage for a long time until it's
finished so when something gets the
stage 4 it is finished you know there
are acceptance tests that are added to
another project called test 262 and
there there has to be at least two
implementations that pass these
acceptance tests it's ready for the next
release of the language spec and APR is
created for the Eknath 262 document now
the cadence that the tc39 has been on
since 2015 is the stage 4 candidates our
selections are made in January of that
year and the new edition of the Aetna
262 document is released in June and
that means that we will soon have yes
2020 we've had es 2015 2016 2017 2018
2019 and now at 2020 the decisions for
ES 2020 have been made and the latest
features have made it to stage 4 some
are already available the 2020 spec will
be published in a couple of months and
if you're interested in knowing there
are several new features worth looking
at one is optional chaining this is how
we can this feature allows us to safely
access deeply nested properties in a
JavaScript
object so imagine you have a JavaScript
object like this one and address some of
the properties on the address or maybe
the address itself is optional of course
everything in JavaScript is optional but
you know what I'm saying in the past to
access a property deep in the object
such as the city you would have to test
every property along the way to make
sure it wasn't null or undefined
the optional chaining can express in one
statement how to get access to an
optional property but we don't have to
test every single every single parent
along the way there's a new feature
called knowledge coalescing it allows
you to test values that are specifically
no or undefined in the past we've had
this this using the two pipes we can say
is this thing false E or or not and you
know if anything that's that can be
false
no undefined empty strings zero all
those kinds of things then you would get
the default value but if you only want
to test no undefined you can now use
double question marks you test for
specifically null or undefined
one thing to note if you're a no js'
developer nodejs 14 wasn't just released
this this past week and it includes
optional chaining and knowledge
coalescing because those are available
in the newer versions of chrome v8
JavaScript engine which is what as i've
mentioned for what ojs uses there's also
a global this which is a consistent way
of accessing the global object
regardless of your environment so in the
browser there's the window object in a
web worker there's the self object and
in nodejs there's the global
so now global this gives you one thing
you can use in case your modules or
codes going to be used across multiple
environments there's a new promise dot
all settled which is similar to promise
to all which we've had in the past
it takes an array of promises and it
resolves when all those promises have
finished however when using promise not
all if one of those promises is rejected
then it returns immediately and and it's
over promise that all settled waits
until all the promises have returned
regardless if they are resolved or
rejected there's a new feature called
dynamic imports which allows us to
dynamically import modules and that
import syntax is a promise that we can
use either the promise syntax or use
async and await so in the second example
here we had a a button listener click
event which means that that module
reported on Jas is only going to get
loaded if someone clicks on the there's
also a match all for regular expressions
now I can't go into the details for the
sake of time but trust me this one
statement this one line is saving a ton
of code that you would have to do in
order to do the what what this new match
all function does now and then there's a
new data type called big int and in the
past the largest integer value you could
have in JavaScript was 2 to the 53rd
power minus 1 that's a really big number
but it turns out we sometimes need
numbers bigger than that and so big int
is now a native feature of the
JavaScript language that allows us to
deal with bigger integers
any really arbitrarily large injure
there's two ways of declared against you
can use the big int instructor or you
can use the letter n on the end of a
number to signal to the JavaScript
compiler our engine that this this
number is a big int value okay
despite the weirdness and the Ward's of
JavaScript there are amazing things that
continue to be created with the language
I mentioned this earlier but
applications like Google Gmail on Google
Maps Google sheets these change the
landscape or web developers and saw it
you know help us to realize what we can
do with the browsers in the JavaScript
language NASA is using nodejs
to help analyze spacesuit data and to
make astronauts more safe JavaScript
making astronauts more safe it's a bold
move I I have to admit but that's what's
being done at Woods law states that any
application that can be written in
JavaScript will eventually be written in
JavaScript and this self-fulfilling
prophecy is no more true than things
like emulators you there are entire
operating systems that have been created
using pure JavaScript there's a DOS
implementation there's a Linux
implementation there's a Commodore 64
emulator and god help us
there's Windows 95 there are so many
things you can do with JavaScript
whether you need to or not and there's
things like Internet of Things with
libraries like johnny-five and node-red
you can do me
music using a tool like banje s I have a
personal project on charter that takes
chord charts and in court pro text
format and turns them into beautifully
formatted yes uhm JavaScript works great
for doing things like that there's games
and then there's desktop apps like
Visual Studio code github desktop and
the slack desktop app those are all
examples of apps created with electron
which is essentially node.js and
chromium or the rendering and that only
just scratches the surface of what you
can do with with JavaScript you can
build really anything you can think of
that you can build with JavaScript you
build with a programming language you
could probably build it javascript may
not always be the best choice for a
given thing but you can do it and the
power is there JavaScript can be
challenging but it's getting better all
the time
and I think the JavaScript language that
we have today is far far better than
what we had years ago and we went
through those years of es 3 and I find
that javascript is now a joy to work
with most of them now here are some of
my thoughts on the future of JavaScript
in the life of JavaScript so far we've
seen the language evolved and the
influenced by a number of other
languages and libraries browsers and
technologies and in the past couple of
years
typescript has gained a lot of momentum
typescript does seem to be becoming the
standard for a type system for
JavaScript if you listen to the
typescript believers you might be
convinced that it solves all the
problems
in JavaScript I don't know I wouldn't go
that far
um Eric Eliot well-known author speaker
and open source developer in the
JavaScript community
he wrote a article called the typescript
tax it's a cost-benefit analysis of
using pine script based on his
experience now his experience can be
different from other people's experience
and is different so it's it's the
scenario of well it depends right but
Eric Elliot makes the case that contrary
to a lot of hype out there typescript
projects can introduce more friction
instead of less friction they can
introduce more time can take more time
to onboard new developers and argues
that a type system for JavaScript will
only prevent a small prevent a small
percentage of bugs the bigger more
costly bugs can't be prevented by a type
system it turns out you know if you
think about it any language a language
that's dynamic or a language that's
static it doesn't matter um can't for
save you from making mistakes I recently
had a conversation with a developer who
said years of using typescript that he
wishes his development team go back to
using plain JavaScript so I've heard
lots and lots of stories from both sides
of the spectrum typescript is great can
do a lot of great things that can help
you to move faster it can help with
large scale projects that can help you
to reduce friction when refactoring code
or it can also increase friction
and cause frustration it could be you
know just like the language of the
JavaScript language itself some of those
things can be solved by education and
experience and and disciplines well
regardless I there are some benefits to
typescript I see the typescript
is continuing to have impact on the web
developer community I find it
interesting that there are members of
the tc39 who use typescript and my
prediction is that we may start to see
the most valuable ideas in typescript
begin to make their way into Ekman
script and if that happens will there
continue to be a strong case for
typescript I look forward to a day when
maybe we no longer need to use a tool
like typescript we have everything that
we need in the Java you know the pure
JavaScript regardless I believe that
there is a strong case for investing in
JavaScript the good the power the
flexibility the university allottee that
it's everywhere those things in my mind
far outweigh the negatives the language
as I mentioned before has improved
tremendously in recent years and I
believe it's only going to get better
thank you javascript for enriching our
lives or keeping us on our toes and for
making us humble when we're tempted to
believe that we have it all figured out
I believe that all of us and technology
have an incredible opportunity and a
responsibility to make a positive impact
on our workplaces our community and the
world I
challenged you to take the things that
you've been learning at NDC Porto you
share your experiences with others and
you help make our world a better place
for everyone wherever you are I hope you
stay safe you cherish the time that you
have with your loved ones you make the
most of the gifts and the talents that
you are blessed with and you get out
there and you be awesome if you have any
questions please ask me on slack and I
will answer them the best I can
thanks everyone and I hope you have a
great rest of your day